それから結論 仏教の世界では中道を歩むということをするんです
だから使わないでもったいぶって置いておくこともしないんです
使いすぎもしないんです
もう明確にブッダの教典ではあるんですね
物惜しみはダメだと だからといって贅沢もダメだと
適度知って使いなさい
交通ルールに従って制限速度を保って人生の運転するんです
それはブッダの生き方なんです
ちゃんと交通ルールありますからね
生きる交通ルール 制限速度も速度もあります
そこをリミットを守っていれば
ずっと寿命を全うすることができます
何のトラブルもなく そういうわけで
体で使い切るものがありまして
体力 能力などは成長しようと努力するときは使い切った方が良いんです
例えば体力を成長させたい場合は
今持っている体力を使い切らなくちゃいけないんですよ
二十歩ぐらい散歩して健康でいられると思ったら勘違いです
やっぱり歩くならば まあゆっくり歩いたっていいんですけど
かなり疲れるまで歩かないと
体力は成長してこないと
能力も同じなんです 能力もギリギリのところまで能力使い切らないと能力は向上しないんです
勉強なども怠けることなく限度に達するまで努力するんです
勉強したければ 限度まで勉強しなくちゃいけないんです
そうすると早く勉強できるようになります
だから私のやり方は この 1年
2年のコースをとにかく 1ヶ月間で終了するんです
で ものすごく厳しいんですよ
自分自身に対しても なおさら先生も協力してくれないんだから
一人でやるんです とにかく
限度超えるんです それでうまくいったんです
それでもうでないと知識能力は伸びません
たまたま 1週間一回ぐらい
ちょっと 30分ぐらいコーヒー飲みながら英会話したってもね
4学年経っても英会話できませんよ
私たちは限度を超えてやったんです
で 中学校でもシンハラ語しか知らなかったんです
すっごくバカにされちゃったんだよ
田舎から来て この学校に入って
何やこれ？とかね で あるクラスに入れちゃって
他の授業は何もなし  1 日 5件くらい英語だけ
そこでこの子の本書いてくださいと言うたら
本屋さんに行ってテキスト買っていくんですね
たくさんの  2週間の本が全部終わってるんです
はい 次こういうこういう本書いてください
で また行って また書いて
また 1 日もうチャプターもう 5つぐらい飛ばすやるんです
宿題今やりなさい   1時間以内でもうもう英語のシステム 100とかも書くんです
例えば 1つの文章 例えばシンプルプレゼンツということ
あの なんて言いますかわかりませんだけど
学ばなくちゃあかんというと
大体 400ぐらいセンテンスを言うんです
シンプルプレゼンで ではパストパーフェクトやらなくちゃと
と パストパーフェクトできてる文章っていうのは
400ぐらいキャーってやる
子供でしょうね もう本当に苦しいというか
もうやがてもうもうもう癖になっちゃって
もう知らないうちに もう次
はい 次 まあ授業ということで
まあどうなるかというと
もう先生たちは何語で喋ってるかとももう区別つかないんです
本当は 時々授業を英語でやったりとか
時々シンハラ語で半分やったりとかね
何語で全然気がつかない
そのまま で これゆっくりやるとね
もうノバのなんだかといって 10
万ぐらい払って  まあ日本に住んでいる外人もいるでしょうに
もう私よりもすごい年住んでる人もいますけど
ろくに日本語喋れないとか
体力 能力などは伸びていくんです
その場合は しかし 能力の限度を超えようとすると
因縁は自分の管理から離れて暴走するんです
それでも限度があるんです
例えば もう今日徹夜して勉強しなさいと
あんた怠けたんだからと
いいんですけど  1ヶ月間徹夜しなさいと言っちゃうと
病院に運ぶ羽目になるんです
それは伸びません それ
限度がそれでもあります
やっぱり限度を超えてはいけませんだけど
エネルギーは使い切るんです
それで使い切らないものもあります
使い切ってはならない
もうちょっと残した方がいいんです
それは何でしょうか 食べること
音楽を聴くこと 目を楽しめること
その他の遊びなどは使い切らない方が正しい
それは使い切ったらダメです
壊れます だから楽しむ世界
見たり食べたり 味わったり
嗅いでみたりとかね 俗世間で
そこは体力ある限りやるぞとやってはいけません
お金ある限り遊んでやるぞとは絶対ダメなんです
これはもうもっと遊べると勘違で止めなくちゃいけない
ご飯はもっと食べられるのに
これでカットしなくちゃいけないんです
それは使い切ってはならないもの
これで世間はどうです？それはあべこべでしょう
遊ぶ時 若者は遊び使い切るんですよ
勉強は残しておくんです
酒飲むことになっちゃうと
もう飲み切るんですね
倒れるまで 大学でもね
忘年会やったりして もう病院に運ぶんだからね
体力もないし若いし 一気飲みとかなんとかして
そいつら一気飲めるんで
勉強は一気やったらどうですかね
だって迷惑でしょ 私にしたってもう
あれ勉強してか これ勉強やっていうと
もうちょっと怪我たそうんですよ
だったら相当頭悪いでしょ
結構助かるのはもう大学に入ってない人は結構助かってます
だからあべこべな使い切ってはならないものは使い切る
使い切りなさいというものは使い切らない
楽しみの量は決まってるから
早くも使い切ると後は生きていられなくなります
30歳で消化機能が壊れたらどうしますかね？それからは
35歳で腎臓が悪くなったらどうするんですかね
40歳で心臓後身なんだかなんとかいうね
病気になったらどうするんですかね
二十歳になっても歯が壊れていると
どういうことでしょう
だからそれは回数券になりますから
やっぱりそこと残した方がいいんです
思考する時でもリミットが超えると狂うんです
そこでこの現に接心に書いたんですけどだけ書いたんですけど
次の考えること この考えることを気をつけてほしいんです
あまりにも考えてはならないんです
だからほとんど妄想をやってますから
みんな気づいてないだけで
私にしてみれば この無駄な思考っていうのは
もうそれよりはもうおぶす頭にかぶされたって
あんまり嫌な気分になる
洗っちゃえばいいんだからね
人と無駄な思考で喋ることはものすごく疲れる
時間余っていたら 私は何もしないで心を止めてぼけっといるについているんです
でもあちこちごちゃごちゃごちゃ動きますけどね
頭をストップさせるんです
ある程度で 何か思考が入っても
すぐそれはそこでストップして別なことですね
だからこの思考もずっと延々と考えちゃうと
もう完璧にコミットしまう
もう管理できなくなっちゃうんです
死ぬ時もいくらか業の残りがこれ間違いあった方が良い
生まれる時 貯金持って生まれるでしょう
貯金全部ガラガラにして死ぬんじゃないんです
まだまだ 20年分残ってるんだろうというところで
80歳で死んだ方がいいんです
本当は 80年までの貯金なんですけど
80年も生きていたんですけど
また 20  20年分は節約して残っていると
そうなってくると この寝たきりになったり
認知障害になったり あれこれとか
もう全くこのね 機械に植物になって死ぬことはないんです
まあ寿命になったら もう買い物に行った途中でそのまま倒れて死にましたと
ぽっくりと 死ぬ時のもうちょっと 30分前でも何か仕事をしているんですって
そういう人がいるんです
だから誰も悲しくてもなくて
楽しいんですね ものすごく可愛いし
もう 80歳なんで元気バリバリで
もう家の仕事もするし
田んぼのこともするし
それでちょっと買い物に行ってくるぞと言ったところで
貧血で倒れていたんだと
で そのまま逝っちゃったと
だからそれは業がまだまだ残っている
使い切っていない 使い切らないもの
体には賞味期限があるので
使い切った方が良いのではないでしょうか
と思うでしょう 私は今
賞味期限のことをよくよく言ったんだからね
二十歳の時できなかったことは 60歳でやるものじゃないとも言ったでしょうね
だったら使い切った方が正しいんじゃないかと
二十歳でやるやるべきことはとっくにやった方がいいんじゃないかと
そうでもないんです 違います
刺激に執着する 依存する
快楽に酔うんですよ 例えば二十歳の時は遊んでもいいんですよ
ものすごく体力ありますから
いろんなことをやったり
いろんなこと もう山に行ったり
川に行ったり いろんなことをして人生楽しんでもいいんだけど
問題は快楽に依存するんですよ
それが危ないんですね
酔っちゃいますよ したがって
必ずリミットを超えるんです
体に賞味期限があるんだからといって使い切ろうとすると
知らず知らずリミットを超えるんです
そこは危険です 例えば若者は遊んでいると
なんのことなくリミットを超えるでしょう
すぐリミットを超える
遊んで悪くはないんです
じゃあ遊び切るそうと思ったところで
リミット これリミットを超えるのは依存するんだからね
快楽に快楽に酔っちゃいます
酔っちゃって じゃあやっちゃいましょうということになるんです
短命になるか 病弱になり
重荷になって生きる生きなった生き方をするかですね
だから体に賞味期限があっても使い切ってはならない
なぜならば寿命が縮みます
部品 1個でも壊れたら総合依存だから全体的に体が壊れます
あるいはただ植物人間になってしまいます
だから使い切ってはならないんです
命の節約と投資  仏教の言葉ではないんで
俗世間の言葉ですけど
中身は仏教です 皆様知っている節約とこちらの節約は違います
理性のある人は節約しつつ投資家になるんです
経済でもいい人生でしょう
節約しつつ投資家ですと結構金持ちになりますね
命の場合も同じことです
結構豊かになります 五根に対して腹八分の生き方をする
眼耳鼻舌身に対して腹八分目という法則
使い切りません やることは何もない
今日は休みだから 1 日中テレビ見る方ってダメです
ある時間リミット切ってこれぐらい
次の時間で別なものを探そうと
私も音楽を聴いたりするんですけど
ギリギリ 3 曲です 4曲目は聞きません
それは思い存分聞くんです
それが ものすごく音 綺麗な音で
もうあれこれと工夫して
もうできるだけ臨場感作って聞くんです
だからといって まあ 1曲では十分で
まあせいせい苦労したんだから 1
曲目聞いてやるぞと まあついでにあと 1曲と
3番目は結構もう大変です
それで全部消す ですから
五根 腹八分目というのは食べることについてなんですけど
そう 全部まとめて腹八分目という理屈
投資とは快楽のために悪を犯さないこと
善行為をすることです
それは投資なんです 楽しみためだからといって悪を犯してはならない
それやってはならないんです
あんた楽しいんだからといって
この魚たちはよくも生命の命を元に持てあせんで
漁師たちの魚獲りは まあそれは商売でね
もう食べるためにやってますけど
このものすごく金かかって
ボートに乗って海まで行って
1 日中海にいて 殺して楽しむと
あれまた世界でいかに悪魔に支配されているかというと
あれこそ金持ちの遊びなんですね
という風にもするんだから
金のない人々は借金してやるんです
だから楽しみのために悪楽しんでもいいんだけど
楽しむために悪をしてはいけません
それから善行為をする
それが投資なんですよ
一番 一日一善でも良いから何かの善行為を投資しなくてはならないんです
だから一日一善することも
自分が命に投資しているんです
だから悪をする人々は命に価値
命を無駄にしているんです
命は大事だ大事だと口先で言うだけで
だったらなんで善行為しないんですかね
善行為こそが命に投資でしょうに
投資しないですよ そのものを大事に思わなきゃ
株買ってる人は あの会社素晴らしい
だから株買ってやるぞと思わないでしょうに
あの会社はもう成長するぞと思っちゃうと
その会社の株を買うでしょうに
だから命に投資する人は命を大事にしているんです
あまり恵まれた生まれでなくても
一日千日々善行為を投資すると
今の業も花を咲くんです
だから生まれは恵まれてなくても
その人はその日から悪悪いことをしないで
善行為で投資すると まあすごく成功するんです
あの業っていうのは必ずやりますよ
花咲かないんですよ 栄養がなくて
だから毎日善行為すると
それが過去の業にも栄養になるんです
だから生まれた回数券は変えられませんだけど
これが一等席の回数券になるんです
飛行機ではファーストクラスのチケットになるんです
本当は我々は持っているチケットは
あの 何といいますか あれはキャンセル待ちなんです
名前は入れてありますけど
飛行空港に行ってキャンセル待ち
ずっと待たなくちゃいけないんです
これ 一日人生に投資するならば
あのキャンセル待ちじゃなくてファーストクラスになるんです
そうすると空港会社の人々は来て挨拶をして連れて行くんです
はい どうぞこちらへ で
ラウンジに座ってもらって
自分がいるところに食べ物やら飲み物やら持ってきて
ちゃんと時間になってくると
あの 今時間ですけどと言って
一緒に飛行機に乗るところまで連れて行くんです
だからそういう人生になるんですよ
どんな人でも 毎日投資して生きているならば
だから自分が不幸な生まれだとかね
ガチガチ言うんじゃないんですよ
それはまあ 今更どうでもいいんだからね
これから投資すればいいんです
この投資するのは来世のためなんですけど
やっぱり利益が今も入ってきて
業が業に栄養が入るんです
慈しみの念と行為両方はほとんどの善行為が含むので最大の投資です
この慈しみ 慈しみの念と行為は
行為の中に他の善行為全部入っているんです
例えば人にお金をあげるのも
その人のことを心配しているでしょうに
人にご飯をあげることも心配しているからでしょうに
病院に行って あるいは老人ホームに行ってボランティアすると
それも善行為でしょうに
それも慈しみがあるからでしょ
だから慈しみの中に全部入っています
サマーディ瞑想は心の投資です
瞑想でもしてみればしてみれば
心にも投資することになる
立派な心で生まれるんです
観察瞑想は智慧の投資です
観察瞑想 ヴィパッサナー瞑想っていうのは
智慧開発するための投資になるんです
だから投資株は 3 3社です
3社の株も買わなくちゃいけないんです
智慧のある人は輪廻をしてもいつでもリーダー的な存在で
その中でまたヴィパッサナー瞑想
観察瞑想をする人々は
どこに生まれても金持ちになってもならなくてもリーダーなんです
この子分にはなりません
全部支配する 支配ではなくて
すごく力があって 活発でみんなを導くぐらいのことはできます
智慧は苦しみ 輪廻を完全に脱出するはしごです
それで完全に脱出したければ
苦しみを はしごは智慧なんですね
それそのように命の節約と投資
節約っていうのは使い切らないこと
サラ金できる人 罪を犯す人
善行為をしない人は 業の残高をすべて下ろすんです
一発で 罪を一つ起こしたらね
80年使い使うはずの残高はね
全部下ろしたことになります
一向で 日々借金 借金が増える生き方になるんです
罪の人が 1日生きると
ものすごい借金なんです
どんどん増える 利息の上でまた利息がかかるんです
借りたのは 10万円ですけど
1,000万払っているのに
まだ借金そのままやということになるんです
前後の借りはこの上のない危険なのです
それは戦後の借りです
ということはあまりわからないでしょうね
例えば悪いことをして贅沢しているでしょ
不正働かしちゃって 嘘を言って
国民黙って投票して選挙で勝ったりとか
企画をごまかしたりして金儲かりとか儲かってますよ
だから儲かった分は戦後なんですよ
例えば会社でもうもうもう建築会社で企画をいろいろごまかしたり
いろんなことをしたりして
もうもうどんどん儲かる
本当にマイホーム作って
車買って 飛行機も買って
いろいろすごいゴージャスな生活はしてますよ
全部戦後遺の結果なんです
しかし この人は借りてます
戦後遺は 本当は幸福になる
なんて言いますか 資格はないんです
ごまかし屋だから 詐欺師だから
詐欺師は刑務所に行くべきである
これで詐欺師は豪華な家で住んでるんだから
それで皆さんはよく間違うでしょ
やっぱりこの世の中で悪いことをすると結構うまくいくんだぞとかね
あれって大変危ないんですよ
彼らが借金しています
借金して戦後遺を食べているんです
しかし 悪徳業者からサラ金取ったような感じなんです
どんどん増えるんです
業の借金が この世でも罰を受けたり
死後地獄など不幸な不幸に生まれたりするんです
だからもうこの世の中でも見た目だけ贅沢するんですけど
ビクビクしなくちゃいけないわ
いろんな資料をごまかさなくちゃいけないわ
いろんなとこでお金隠しておかなくちゃいけないわ
いろいろ それでも 貸せる場合は億単位で貸せる人々も刑務所にいますからね
千万単位ではなくて まああれでは 300ぐらいは儲かる
じゃあ 300ぐらい出しましょうか
300 というのは 300 億なんです
それでも逮捕されるでしょ
借りたものを返せない限り
幸福な生き生まれはできなくなるんです
これは因果法則だから
ごまかしきかない 何一つ
だから借りたならば 悪業ばっかりしながら贅沢したならば
これは全部返さない限りは地獄に落ちても上がってはこないんです
強盗は遊びません 心の限度
はい これで生命の限度終わりました
それから心論に入って
心だけとっても またまた限度っていうのはあるんです
えーと 貪瞋痴の心で皆能力開発に知識を増やすために努力しています
貪瞋痴は心の伸びに障害になるものです
貪瞋痴っていうのは 心は伸ばさないんです
硬くするんです がむしゃらに頑張っても大した伸び成長はありません
貪瞋痴の心でがむしゃらに頑張ったんだからといって
そんな驚くほど成長はないんです
限度を超える心が暴走して壊れるんです
だからそこを暴走するんで
限度を超えると 貪瞋痴があると心はそれほど伸びないんです
いくら勉強しても いくら研究しても
ものすごく苦労してなんとか発展するだけで
大したことはありません
それでも限度を超えて頑張っちゃうと
結局は病院で終わるんです
大学教授ではなくて 犯罪
罪を犯す人と同じ結果になるんです
だから普通 俗世間で貪瞋痴で生きてるでしょ
みんな頑張ってるでしょ
でも限度を超えちゃうと
結果は罪を犯す人と同じなんです
不幸になるんです 頭イカれるんです
だから私たちは別に宗教に興味ないんだ
もう仕事はうまくいってるんだ
商売は思う通り乗ってるんだ
まあ元気でいるんだとかね
そんなのはいらんとか
そんな態度を取っても限度を超えちゃいますよ
とにかく貪瞋痴のそれでもいかれちゃいます
いいところには生まれません
だから金持ちの人でも死にないで
そこに財産どうしようか
会社どうしようか あれやこれやとかね
まあ時々金があるんだから
もう 75歳で 80 もう 75歳で 33歳の女の子と結婚する
これは明らかにもう遊び女で
もうあんなもう金持ちの社会で生活できる人でもなんでもないんです
全部金持っていかれるんです
金持っていくのはいいんだけど
会社まで潰れるんだから管理できないでしょ
だからその時は前の奥さんはもう4人5人ぐらいいるんだからね
そういう人々はね そちらの子供もいるんだから
ものすごく激しい醜い争いになったりして
死ぬ人は一生懸命苦労して大会社作ったんですけど
地獄に行かなくちゃいけないんです
この醜い争いに関わりますからね
心の限度は不可思議 心の限度は体の限度みたいにわかりやすいものじゃないんです
世の中 心はなんでもないしね
貪瞋痴という不純物を睡眠状態にして心を伸ばすならば
人間に想像できないほど心が伸びるんです
本当は心には制限ないと言っても過言じゃないんです
それぐらい伸びるんです
金属の中で金みたいなもんですよ
いくら薄くても伸びます
鉄やら鉛と違います しかし
金でも薄くミクロンまで伸びるのは純金であるならばなんです
でないとできません ミクロンまでは伸びません
純金でない それで人は貪瞋痴という不純物を沈んで置いておくんです
沈んでおいちゃうと 心がざーっと伸びるんです
不純物されると伸びなくなるんです
あのゴム製品の中で ゴムにいろんな化学物質を入れるでしょ
例えば製品は伸びてほしい場合は何か化学物質ってゴムはいくらでも伸びます
伸びるんだけど 例えば風船みたいにね
そう簡単に割れないとか
またタイヤとかは伸びませんね
タイヤにはこのサルファダイヤとか何とか入れます
入れるとゴムもゴムなんですけど
伸びてはこないんです
伸びちゃうと困りますから
タイヤは しかし ゴムの機能なんです
クッション機能はしてくれます
が 伸びません 伸びると困るんだから
中何層も 何と言いますか
この布みたいなものでコーティングしています
それにゴムのいろいろ伸び方ありまして
いろんなゴム製品の場合はそれぞれのまあ
不純物を管理して伸びるようにするんです
人相力などの超能力は非論理的な物語ではありません
ものすごく自然なものなんです
人相っていうのは しかし
貪瞋痴を抑えておかないと
だから現代人にはあり得ません
なぜならば 人相はみんな欲しいんだけど
あれはテレビで出るためなんです
あれ みんなに見せるためなんです
あるいは大勢の信者さんにとって
有名になるために貪瞋痴でしょ
ダメです できない 物質的な対象に依存しつつ心が伸びる状態は色界禅定なのです
で  4つあります かなり伸びると禅定というんです
心は物質に大体依存しています
だから物質に依存しつつも心は伸びます
伸びると伸びると４段階で伸びるんです
大体４番目に行ったら
ものすごい人相はいくらでもできます
そのその訓練はありますけど
まあできます 第一禅定でさえも俗世間の次元を超えています
ただ瞑想して第一禅定に入ったっても
もう俗世間のレベルは超えています
それは心の伸びなんです
物質に依存することから解放されると
心はさらに伸びるんです
今 我々の心は肉体に依存していますね
肉体から離れることできれば
肉体から一時的に離れたり
離脱したりはしますけど
それは物質なんです まあこの微妙な物質がいろいろあります
だからそれは違います
本当に素粒子レベルの物質からの心を離れる
離れてみるんです これはもう想像できませんよ
それぐらい 離れちゃうと物質から
無辺無限という概念をその時初めて経験できるんです
みんなペラペラ話してるでしょ
無限とかね わかってませんよ
無限わかるはずもない
頭で経験できるはずもない
無辺っていうのは空間的
無限っていうのは時間的
時空関係の無限は経験できません
そこで心は物質から離れてみると経験できます １
空無辺 ２色無辺 ３無だけという３段階段階があります
その場合は３段階があります
もうどんどんどんどん
それは皆様理解しようとしないでください
これはもう 二回半超えてます
最終的にこれは限度 これ以上は伸びません
非想非非想定という いわゆる心があるとも言えないし
ないとも言えない いわゆる認識がない
ないとも言えないんだというところは最後の伸びなんです
それ以上伸びません それは心の限度
それは人間に理解できないんですね
説明は仏教以外はないんです
ヨーガチャーラスートラとか何とか
ヒンドゥー教にも瞑想の本がありますけど
そんな明確でもないし
まあそれほど合ってない
まあそれも仏教後で書かれたもんでね
古いものでもないんです
またもう一つ 心の粘度限度があります
それは非認識って言うんです
非想ではなくて非認識
まあ非想と言っちゃってもいいんですけど
感情的に生きることを嫌がる
好まない人は瞑想して禅定に達して
色界の 4 までね 生きることを否定する気持ちを実践するんです
例えば まあ嫌だ この世の中生きていきたくないんだとかね
もう苦しいんだ 生きることは嫌だとか
あれ感情ですよ そんなのは
それで瞑想にする 瞑想にすると
当然真面目な人だったら
第1 2 3 4 まで禅定が上がる
上がってからも やっぱり生きることは大嫌い
とにかく生きることをやめたいと言うと
認識が停止するんです
その人の心は死後長い時間停止するんです
心はそのまま停止するんです
この瞑想は仏教では禁止しています
やらないで 最初から間違っています
何個も心ない状態ではいられます
心ない状態でいたって
このマイクロフォンにも心がないんです
だから何が面白いんですかね
何が価値でしょうかね
もうだからあまり意味がない
仏教は禁止している瞑想で
これも結構高いレベルの瞑想なんです
で 彼らの欠点というのは
感情的に生きること嫌だと
生きることは嫌でも好きでもどちらでも言えないものでしょうに
ずっと説明したでしょうに
この価値入れるものじゃないんです
価値入れられないということは危険
それも価値でしょうに
だからこの感情で好きと言ったっても間違い
嫌いと言ったって間違いなんです
好き嫌いを乗り越えなくちゃいけないんです
そんなのは無常だから別にいいんじゃないかって
勝手にすればいいんだと
あれ 関わり持たないことなんです
執着するということなんです
煩悩がある人は 生を正当化しても否定しても大したことではありません
煩悩がある人は もう生を賛嘆したってもどうったことはない
あるいは生きることは苦しみであるとか
大したことはないんです
はい 次の心の限度 ジェラス
仏説を理解して瞑想する人は
8 禅定の過程で幻想の無常か空か無我を観察して
生に対する執着を断つんです
だから仏教の瞑想のプロセスはここ
微妙な違うところ この 1 から 8 まで禅定があります
このどちらかに入って
あるいは入る前からでも
無常か空か無我であると
一切の現象は だから喜びにも値しない
嫌がるにも値しない 嫌われるにも値しない
執着にも値 まあまあどうったことはないという
そこは無執着の気持ちなんです
この無執着で働いているんです
何か捨てるんじゃないんです
執着を断つんです 執着は心にあるんです
花が欲しいだったら 花を持つことはバカバカらしい
花欲しくなったのは自分の執着なんです
だからこの心の執着を断つんです
自然になくなってしまいます
また 執着も断つと言ったっても
パッと自然に消えます
これがジェラスというものです
心の成長は限度ではなく
終了になるんです その場合は限度と言わない
心の成長は終了しましたと
というんです 卒業しましたと
すべて単位をそろって
試験も合格して 先生たちにも認められて褒められて
無事卒業しました 注意
否定と無執着は異なるものです
だから前のスライドで説明したこの否認式戦場
あれは涅槃じゃないんです
あれは否定する人々が達する極限的な感情なんです
仏教は無執着という否定するんじゃないんです
無執着 否定も肯定もしない
終わったみたい 心を育てましょうということ
だから育てるべきなのは心なんです
肉体至上主義では苦しみと矛盾しか現れない
俗世間は肉体至上主義で生きてます
生きてます だから世間であるのは苦しみと矛盾ですね
心を育てるべき 心は宇宙さえも支配できる能力が潜んでいることは全くわかっていない
肉体を育てようと無理をして苦しんで生きるのです
みんな肉体を育てている
これは賞味期限があるし
保証期間もあるし これはもうあまり意味がない
朽ちてゆく心を心 朽ちてゆく
心を閉じ込まれる肉体を心配することを控えて
心に自分の力を発揮できるチャンスを与える
仏教でいうのはチャンスを与えてくださいと心に
この朽ちてゆく体に肉体にもう関わるんじゃないんだよ
心に成長するチャンスを与えなさい
チャンスを与えたら成長するんです
なぜならば 心のエネルギーというのは
地球と宇宙を支配するぐらいのエネルギーを持っています
それで幸福になるということ
幸福は心が作るものです
だから心を育てることしか
もうもう異論はというかね
まあやることほか選択ないんです
今日のテーマにあまり関係ない
宣伝にありましたから
ここでちょっと言いますけどね
これは追加説になります
もうサービスと売りすぎなんですけど
追加説するところじゃないんです
あの 5人の王子たちの話
これパンチャラディスって言うんですね
で 最高の贅沢快楽は色か声か香りか味か触かという議論が生じた
ある 5人の王子たちの王子だって
パーリ語では王と言うんですね
まあ地方地方ちょこちょこと管理しているんだから
まあお釈迦様の時代でしたけどね
しかし地方の大名でしたからね
王とは言うんです 彼らが最高な贅沢っていうのは
見えるものではいえ 聞こえるもの
音 いえいえ 香りだよとか
この 5人がお互い自分の色を持っていて
結構 問題になったと  5人の王は互いに違い意見を交わしたかったり
それでコーサラ王様がどちらでしょうかね
見るものは最高か 味は最高か
比較したくなっちゃう
人間には究極の幸福はどちらから来るんでしょうか
見るものから 聞くものから
嗅ぐものから 味わうものから
あるいは体に触れるものからでしょうか
一人一人が一つ一つ取っちゃったんです
コーサラ王様にはもうわからなくなっちゃったんです
わからなくなっちゃって
お釈迦様に聞いたんです
ある人に見るものは色が刺激的です
これは人の差ですよ ある人にものを見ると刺激的で興奮しちゃって
感動しちゃって 涙ポロポロ流しちゃうんですね
快楽を感じます 同じようなが
別な人にはそうではありません
ある人が何か見て感動して
涙流して もう倒れるかもしれません
あまりにももう楽しくて
隣にいる人はなんだこれ？って誰も喜ばないんです
自分が快楽を感じる 満足を感じる
色が最高だと だから本人が腰が抜けるほど
あれは楽しく美しかったと
音楽を聴いてこんな腰が抜けることは一度もないんだ
その人は言う しかし 隣の友達はそんな程度のものか
これはむしろ無礼じゃないのか
だから それ個人差なんです
それ以上優れている色を求めようともしない
だから 一つの美しいものを見て感動した人は
これより美しいものが欲しいと思わないでしょ
もっと美しいものを見たともうとっくに感動しているんだから
これこそすごいと思うだけ
彼にその色が最高最小なものになるのです
だからその人は この見たものは最高である
最も優れているものであると
そこにヴィパッサナーするのです
てたっさルーパアヌッタラホントにという
で コメント この人は無常たる色で成長を止めるんです
これはコメントだから私のコメントなんで
ブッダの言葉じゃないんです
お釈迦様はあそこでストップするんです
そこはあなたがでもわかるでしょうと
まあそんな程度じゃないんだから
コメントつけます この見るものが最高贅沢やと思った人が見るものって無常でしょ？無常なに見るものに執着するんですね
これで他探しませんでしょ
他探さないということは成長を止めることです
色に依存する色至上主義者になる
先があることは見えない
色に陥るんです そこで根を下ろしちゃうんです
それで虫を捕まえた 捕まえるんです
目の刺激に弱い人は 見える対象に束縛されるのです
だから この肉体のプログラムが作るでしょ
目がちょっと敏感に作ってくれると弱いんですね
目は弱いということは
この刺激に弱い 病みつきになる
視力がそれほどない人にとってはどうでもいいんだけど
よく視力がある人は目は疲れませんよ
だから美しいものには弱くなっちゃうんです
音に弱い人 代わりに弱い人
味に弱い人 観測に弱い人の説明も以上と同じです
みんな引っかかるということで
五根の対象は人を俗世間に束縛される
肉体的快楽は普遍的というのは間違いです
だから人間誰でも食べたり飲んだりして楽しいでしょというのはとんでもない嘘です
それぞれ弱い奴らがそれを楽しむのです
ただ 胃が弱い人はもうごちそうパーティーを楽しめないでしょう
面白いこともない 香りも嫌い
しかし 酒が好きで胃が強い人はもう毎日のパーティーが好きなんです
耳がいい人は音楽にはもう引っ張られてしまいます
難聴の人にとってはですね
そこで個人差がありまして
普遍的な快楽ではない
ある人は最高だという意識は
またある人は嫌いと思うんだからね
だから 俗世間の快楽には普遍性がないんです
それがお釈迦様がおっしゃったかった答えなんです
幸福は普遍性でなければいけません
あんたが言うことは普遍性がないんだと
個人差ありますよ だから本望ではありません
人の好みに普遍性がないんです
人の好みにとやかく言うのも正しくない
だから我々も人の好みにとやかく言ってはいけません
あの人はもう煎餅ばっかり食ってるんだよとか
何あの人は あの人は50歳になってもカップラーメン食べてる
面白い人ですね あのやつ
あの人聴いてる音楽はなんとかアフリカンの音楽やアメリカの音楽聴いてないんだと
それは別に差別するでしょう
そうすると頭悪いんです
人間の好みはもうどうしようもないことなんです
犬は好きな人もいるし
猫が好きな人もいるし
犬も猫も嫌いだけどヘビを好きな人もいるんです
放っておいてください
よかった 人の好みは というのが仏教の立場なんで
仏教はもう全然放っておくんですよ
だからタイでも行ってみてください
仏教の国ですけど 何がないのかと調べるしかないんです
何でもあるんです 変人も何でもいるんです
しかし差別はしません
放っておくのです 精進
有名なバイオリン ヴィーナーの例えがありますね
皆様知ってますね それは弦を緩んではならないでしょう
また 強く引っ張ってもならないでしょ
ヴィーナー弾けませんだからね
ヴィーナーというのは現代的に言えばバイオリンですね
琵琶ですね 曲に合わせて調整するんです
やりすぎも手抜きもやめて
効率的に努力するんです
ですから 俗世間であろうか
修行であろうか 我々は効率的に弦を締めすぎもなく
緩めすぎもなく どんな曲を演奏するのかと
それに合わせて調整して弾けばいいんです
やはり精進すればいい
それは正精進というんです
解脱さえも 七覚支が均等に成長したところで起こるものです
ちゃんと調整していないと起こりません
はい それで以上でしょうね
はい 以上です はい そういうことで
現状っていう言葉はね
随分簡単な常識ですけど
仏教になってくるとそんなものになります
最後にね 降の文を皆さんといただいて終わります
降の文 仏教の三宝に帰依し
戒を守り 慈悲の瞑想とヴィパッサナー修行によって得られたこの功徳を
神々 先祖 父母 両親 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の生きとし生けるものに回向いたします
この功徳によって すべての生きとし生けるものが幸福に暮らせますように
そして解脱が得られますように
サッビーティホーイワンジャントーサンバローホーリナッセットーマーテーバワットワンテラーヨアスケリーガーヨコーバワーババトゥサンバマンガラントゥサンバデーヴァター
サッ
バ ブッダヌバヴェーナ サッバ ダンマヌバヴェーナ サッバ サンガヌバヴェーナ サダー スッティ
ヴァヴァントゥノ アビワダナシーリッサーニッチャン ワッダパジャイノ チャッタロ ダンマ ワッダンティ アユワンロ スカンバラン
サーリプッタ サーリプッタ
今日は本当に長い時間申し訳ございませんでした
こんな時間かかると思わなかったんですけど
どうもありがとうございました
ありがとうございました